[Music]
the Washington free beacon reported
recently that the Obama administration
skirted key US sanctions to grant Iran
access to billions in hard currency
despite public assurances that the
administration was engaged in no such
action according to a new congressional
investigation and it gets even worse the
investigation published Wednesday by the
house permanent Subcommittee on
investigations further discloses secret
efforts by top Obama administration
officials to assure European countries
they would receive a pass from US
sanctions if they engaged in business
with Iran this revelation comes after
the news that came to light in February
that according to bill Gertz in The
Washington Times the US government has
traced some of the 1.7 billion released
to Iran by the Obama administration to
Iranian backed terrorists in the two
years since the cash was transferred now
there's a law that applies to this
situation u.s. code 2381 says whoever
owing allegiance to the United States
levies war against them or adheres to
their enemies giving them aid and
comfort within the United States or
elsewhere is guilty of treason and shall
suffer death or shall be imprisoned not
less than five years and fined under
this title but not less than $10,000 and
shall be incapable of holding any office
under the United States in a sane
political environment Barack Obama would
be tried for treason Barack Obama has
planted seeds that will be bearing
bitter fruit for years and probably
decades to come he is without any doubt
the worst president in American history
now you might say wait a minute Fillmore
Pierce Buchanan yes the doughface
presidents made the Civil War inevitable
but worse came later grant blind to
corruption and out of his depth yes but
there have been worse Wilson well he was
a black-hearted Presbyterian bigot and
he arguably gave the world Hitler in
World War two because of the Treaty of
Versailles so he's definitely in the
Final Four
warren g harding no his tax cuts and
return to normalcy got the american
economy and the 20s
boring as they used to say FDR in LBJ
gave us the modern welfare state and
dependent classes that automatically
vote Democrat the full bill and the
damage they did hasn't yet been
presented Nixon was a crook and an
economic leftist who betrayed Taiwan for
the People's Republic of China his
record certainly isn't good
Carter nothing good can be said about
his four years of sanctimony and
incompetence but there is one thing
Barack Obama has on all his competitors
treason he showered hundreds of billions
of dollars on the Islamic Republic of
Iran there are those who say well it was
their money it belonged to the Iranian
government but was frozen and not paid
since 1979 yeah that's right and there
was a reason for that
not even Jimmy Carter who made the
Islamic Republic of Iran possible
thought that money which had been paid
by the Shahs government in a canceled
armed steel belonged to the mullahs who
overthrew the Shah
likewise Reagan George HW Bush Clinton
and George W Bush all thought that the
Islamic Republic was not due money that
was owed to the Shah only Barack Obama
did the definition of treason is giving
aid and comfort to the enemy the leaders
of the Islamic Republic of Iran ordered
their people to chant death to America
in mosques every Friday and repeatedly
vowed that they will ultimately destroy
the United States in the State of Israel
how was giving them billions and helping
them skirt sanctions applied by the US
government not treason other presidents
have been incompetent corrupt dishonest
what have you but which one has
committed treason on a scale to rival
the treason of Barack Obama the Iranians
also operate a global network of Jihad
terror organizations one of which is
Bala is quite active in Mexico now with
the obvious ultimate intention of
crossing the border and committing jihad
massacres of Americans Obama has given a
tremendous boost to these initiatives as
well as to Iran's nuclear program with
his nuclear deal that has given the
Iranians so much money and essentially a
green light to manufacture nuclear
weapons in exchange for absolutely
nothing there's no telling when the
worst consequences of Obama's aid and
comfort to the Islamic Republic of Iran
will be felt even after Trump canceled
the nuke deal
the likely will be felt in one way or
another even as President Trump
continues to move to restore sanctions
and put Iran on notice that its nuclear
activity in global adventurism will not
be tolerated those billions Obama gave
Iran can't be recovered and the Iranian
Sorority spent a great deal on their
jihad cause however this catastrophe
plays out there's one man who will
suffer no consequences for it whatsoever
and that's Barack Obama himself that's
left is privileged it's good to be a
powerful leftist in Washington nowadays
laws up laws are for conservatives I'm
Robert Spitzer Shulman fellow for the
David Horowitz Freedom Center and
director of jihad watch this video has
been brought to you by the Center for
security policy
[Music]